this is a question that i would ask you
it's a brilliant question it's from andy
kidd and he wants to know your top five
films and why oh
i always hate these questions actually
well at least there's five so it's not
like
too difficult but uh top five um one of
them would be saving private ryan just
like probably a definitive war movie for
me just absolutely fantastic um
what else uh i always had real fondness
for uh falling down that michael douglas
movie
the man who i based my image on yeah
great man i need that flat top hairstyle
yeah um
big trouble in little china just because
it's absolute peak john carpenter uh
lovely and cheesy and just really good
fun
so love that one um back to the future
love it um i i could happily watch all
three of them um and just have a great
time but yeah the first one is just
fantastic just real magical movie um and
the last one probably lord of the rings
the fellowship of the ring i think is is
my favorite again a movie you can just
absolutely lose yourself in so those
would be my picks i think but you asked
me next week it would probably be
different ones yeah
[Music]
you